♪
BRIAN: FIRST THE TERROR WATCH
LES YOU HEARD ABOUT THAT.
NOW BORDER AGENT SAY THEY
STOPPED A MEMBER OF THE DEADLY
MS-13 GANG FROM SNEAKING INTO
THE U.S.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE CRIMINALS WHO
ARE ABLE TO GET THROUGH THE ONES
WHO ARE GOOD AT BEING DECEITFUL?
OUR NEXT GUEST KNOWS ALL ABOUT
IT HIS OLDER BROTHER ROCKY WAS
SHOT AND KILLED BY ILLEGAL
CRIMINAL IN 2018 AFTER BEING
ARRESTED AND RELEASED UNDER
CALIFORNIA’S SANCTUARY POLICY.
JODY JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE SEEING THESE NUMBERS, THE
STAGGERING NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
COMING THROUGH THE BORDER THAT
WE CATCH.
WHAT ABOUT THE ONES WE DON’T?
BEFORE WE GET THAT STORY AND
YOUR PERCEPTION, TELL US WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOUR BROTHER.
>> GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME FIRST OF
ALL.
HE WAS MURDERED IN 2018 BY AN
ILLEGAL CRIMINAL ALIEN THAT WAS
ARRESTED TWO DAYS PRIOR BECAUSE
OF THE SANCTUARY CITY LAWS.
HE WAS RELEASED AND SHOT AND
MURDERED BY THIS CRIMINAL.
BRIAN: SO THIS GUY’S NAME IS
GASTAVO GARCIA.
HE WAS ARRESTED ON DRUG CHARGE
HELD IN JAIL ABOUT 10 HOURS AND
THEN RESPONSIBLE FOR SEVERAL
SHOOTINGS, TWO OTHER MURDERS,
CARJACKINGS, MULTIPLE HIGH-SPEED
CHASES.
THIS GUY IS A TRUE MENACE.
HE IS HELL ON EARTH.
AND HE IS STILL HERE AND YOUR
BROTHER ISN’T.
WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT AN ARREST OF
TWO YEMENI TERRORISTS AND THEN
YOU HERE ABOUT AN MS-13 ARREST.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ALONG WITH
THE 19,000 UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
WHO ARE JUST STREAMING INTO OUR
COUNTRY?
>> WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE A CRISIS.
ALL YOU HEAR IS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SCREAMING FOR HELP.
AND THERE IS NOTHING BEING DONE.
WE HAVE A SAYING IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF IT WALKS LIKE A
TALK, TALKS LIKE A DUCK IT’S NOT
A COW, IT’S A DUCK.
DON’T SIT THERE AND TELL ME
THERE IS NOT A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
THERE IS.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LISTEN AND
SEE AND KNOW IT’S A CRISIS.
WE HAD MORE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
CROSS OUR SOUTHERN BORDER LAST
MONTH THAN EVER BEFORE IN
HISTORY.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
IN HISTORY.
BRIAN: RIGHT AND THEY BLAME.
>> IT’S TRULY AMAZING WHAT’S
GOING ON DOWN THERE.
BRIAN: OF COURSE THE WAY IT
DEPOSE AND YOU WOULD KNOW BETTER
THAN I YOU SEND THE FAMILIES WHO
ARE NO THREAT.
YOU SEND THE KIDS WHO ARE NO
THREAT.
THE BORDER AGENTS GO THERE AND
THEN IN COMES MS-13 OR THE DRUG
TRAFFICKERS WITH THE FENTANYL
THAT ARE POISONING THE COUNTRY.
THEY THINK WELL, I’M NOT IN A
BORDER CITY, IT DOESN’T INVOLVE
ME.
THAT’S JUST NOT THE CASE.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT ISN’T THE CASE.
THINK OF HOW MANY THAT’S GETTING
ACROSS GETTING INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IT’S REALLY DESTROYING OUR
WE HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA SB
54.
IT REALLY DROVE A WEDGE BETWEEN
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
IMMIGRATION.
IT JUST STOPPED THEM FROM
COMMUNICATING WITH EACH OTHER.
NOW WE HAVE PROPOSED BILLS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA A.B. 937.
IF YOU STRIP THAT BILL AWAY.
REALLY WHAT IT DOES IS IT JUST
MAKES ’IMPOSSIBLE, AGAINST THE
LAW ACTUALLY TO DEPORT OR REMOVE
ANY FELON, ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
THAT COMMITS A FELONY.
YOU JUST CAN’T DEPORT THEM.
IT’S INSANITY WHAT’S GOING ON
HERE.
STEVE: THE HHS SECRETARY WENT TO
WHHS SECRETARY.
HE KNOWS HOW IT WORKS.
HE KNOWS THE NEED FOR ICE.
YET, WHEN IT COMES TO SANCTUARY
CITIES WHAT HAS ICE BEEN TOLD TO
DO STAND DOWN OR GET OUT, RIGHT?
>> THAT’S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THEIR HANDS ARE TIED.
JUST LOOK AT THE PICTURES WHAT’S
GOING ON DOWN AT THE BORDER.
IT’S JUST LIKE THAT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THESE FELONS ARE COMMITTING
CRIMES, THESE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE COMMITTING CRIMES, FELONS,
FELONIES, GETTING CAUGHT WITH
POUNDS OF METHAMPHETAMINES,
WEAPONS ON THEM, FIREARMS,
NOTHING IS HAPPENING TO THEM.
I MEAN, THEY ARE DOING EARLY
HOURS IN JAIL AND GETTING
RELEASED.
YOU KNOW, A.B. 54, THE SANCTUARY
CITY LAWS, IMMIGRATION HAS TO
HAVE A FEDERAL WARRANT TO HAVE
THESE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HOLD THEM.
AND IT’S IMPOSSIBLE TO DO IT.
BRIAN: THEY JUST DON’T SEEM TO
CARE.
>> THAT’S SAD.
LOOK, I’M NOT A POLITICIAN.
I’M NOT A GOVERNOR, I’M NOT A
SENATOR, I’M NOT A CONGRESSMAN.
I’M JUST A CITIZEN.
I’M AN AMERICAN CITIZEN.
AND WHAT’S GOING ON RIGHT NOW
THEY ARE PROTECTING CRIMINALS,
ILLEGAL ALIEN CRIMINALS.
AND WHEN YOU START DOING THAT
WHEN YOU ARE PROTECTING THEM,
YOU STOP PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITY.
YOU STOP PROTECTING OUR AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
BRIAN: JODY JONES THIS ISN’T RED
OR BLUE IT’S RIGHT AND WRONG.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
BRIAN: WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW IS
FLAT OUT WRONG.
YOU ARE DOING IT IN MEMORY OF
YOUR BROTHER.
YOU SCRAMBLED TO GET UP THIS
MORNING ROCKY WHO WAS KILLED TWO
YEARS AGO.
>> IF I COULD SAY ONE LAST
THICK.
I HEARD PRESIDENT BIDEN SAY THAT
IT’S HIS JOB TO PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WELL, I WANT TO SAY TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN PLEASE PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SECURE OUR SOUTHERN BORDERS.
DO IT NOW, DO IT SOON BECAUSE
IT’S GETTING WORSE BY THE
MINUTE, BY THE HOUR, BY THE DAY.
BRIAN: YEP.
AND WE CAN’T EVEN GET THE VICE